now and how tough is it like you like if
there's ant do you guys ever deal with
animal and Amelia death yeah so do you
guys just Corner deal with that too or
no yeah we deal with all all deaths so
uh now don't get me wrong we've had
people call us because they have a dead
dog or they got bit by a dog and it's
like oh you're calling the coroner's
office huh yeah go to the ER yeah call
your neighbor and call him an [__]
yeah you know that's what's happening
but no um animals well so if you die in
a home that's locked with animals those
animals will eat you really fast
especially a cat dogs will hold out
until they have nothing left to eat but
a cat will remove your head in 24 hours
and I'm not talking I'm talking
literally hair on the floor no head and
nibbling into their chest
um even cats that were loved by their
owners or is it just cats no you think
we're had something with the owner and
they're and they're gonna say this is my
time yeah no they're they're absolutely
feeding on you you I don't care how much
you love that cat and that cat loved you
he's gonna eat you and you know
sometimes we get to cases where there's
uh you can tell that the cat or dog had
been nibbling you know it might be on
the face or the cheek or so uh the toes
but then sometimes it's unbelievable and
one of it was one of my first cases and
I just never never imagined that they
could do that much damage smaller dogs
now a lab a lab won't a labs for some
reason don't eat their owners you know
unless they're locked in for months I
guess they would but I find it more
weenie dogs small dogs and cats cats
cats don't they don't wait you know it's
like a [__] around a barbecue pit a
Cajun I should say around a barbecue pit
they smell that that odor and they start
nibbling so yeah yeah we'll start
snatching next time they want to
appetizer next time you pet in your cat
just know that when you die he's gonna
eat you he's gonna pet you back with his
teeth absolutely what uh and how how
soon after we talking 30 minutes after
yeah probably a hour or two I guess they
started nudists they start nibbling and
I love my cat you know we have cats and
dogs how could you still love your cat
knowing how they're gonna do yeah I
don't care if they eat me after I'm dead
you know that's cold as hell bro well
think about that man my buddy dies bro
we've been friends forever right he's
laying there dude and I [__] carve a
little bit of them off yeah it's pretty
intense I make a [__] sandwich or
something out of my boy [__] Randall
yeah well after an hour they do it they
do it you know I'm kind of new to cats
we just got one to keep the mice down
but yeah oh he's gonna keep the mice
down or he got along he's playing the
long game though dude yeah that's when
they lay on your wrist they checking
your blood pressure dog that's what that
cat is yeah they're waiting for you they
licking their lips wow as is the weenie
dog but weenie dogs will do it too yeah
small dogs I find that small dogs or
they'll jump on jump up on the lap app
of their owner and you know I guess
start nibbling and we'll eat the wheat
the wiener to jump to or not I've never
seen one but absolutely absolutely you
know most of the time it's uh I kind of
feel like they're nudging you to see if
you're still alive you know maybe
licking you at first and then when you
don't respond and then they just start
you know they just go after it it's
pretty intense
um I'm fascinated by that cat that took
somebody's head off they'll take
somebody's head off huh yeah completely
completely and where do they hide it
somewhere oh they eat it oh my God no
I'm even bone I mean they eat bone
there's no skull left it's gone it's a
wig on the ground next to a body if you
can imagine and and down into the chest
I could see their left main stem from
their lung and it's just amazing how
fast the cat can eat you so you know
have a dog door have a cat door not a
bad investment let them leave huh you
know they can get in and out the house
uh as needed yeah we had a lady that had
a cat or a uh she had a panther living
in her house and she didn't even know
this old lady
and it killed someone out of the panther
yeah like a real panther yeah she didn't
know she thought it was like a rescue
cat or whatever and it killed someone at
a
surprise party wow imagine that
dogs I've had dog accidents you know I
love pit bulls they're gorgeous
Dobermans
beautiful animals but I've seen people
that they've just reacted and grabbed
their neck and killed them you know
those animals can be great and they can
be dangerous you know what about some
unique animal dust you ever rolled up
because of Louisiana bro you know I'm
saying anything people some people you
know
net you know that other than you know
having a good pet having a pit bull as a
pet and it biting the owner and getting
them in the right spot you know that no
alligators no no alligators not yet now
now bodies that have been chewed on by
Turtles and possums and other animals
when they're dumped into the water
that's uh that's hard you know that's
tough
but again that's you know not a whole
lot of animal deaths now riding horses
and not knowing how to ride like I had
mentioned horses can really mess you up
you know if you don't know what you're
doing it's a big animal oh yeah
um